all aboard the Biden Express choo
choo Fox sources capturing this crazy
video showing thousands of migrants
waiting to catch trains in Mexico Bound
for the United States right now Biden's
trying to cut a deal with Republicans to
beef up border security and exchange for
Aid to Israel and Ukraine but as usual
Democrats are freaking out Congressional
Hispanic Dems warning Joe that he better
not bring back Trump era immigration
policies members of the radical Squad
chiming in to say how cruel and xenop
phobic to use migrants as bargaining
chips and while those idiots won liberal
cities that actually have to deal with
the mess are crying Uncle New York city
mayor Eric Adams says he's not seeing
any urgency from the White House when it
comes to the migrant crisis in the
city I'm just not seeing uh the you know
the White House and their colleagues up
there understanding that we need a
decompression strategy I've been to DC
times and uh each time I I laid out a
case on uh why the the city that's the
economic engine of the state and the
country uh should not be going through
this walking out would I did not see the
level of urgency all rosan Scot uh your
thoughts on what we're seeing around
here in New York City well this is our
hometown right in fact tomorrow mayor
Adams is going to be on Good Day New
York uh we'll talk about it as you know
he's begging DC and Senator Schumer
who's a big wheel right in DC we haven't
heard him come out and put his arms
around our mayor and say you're right
this is terrible for our city I mean we
know we're stretched To The Ends right
we have the Cardinal come on our show
Cardinal Dolan and and the arch dicese
has been wonderful to the migrants
taking them in trying to get them
clothing and homes and jobs and
everything else they say they're
stretched it's not a figment of our
imagination that this is stretching our
budget but the mayor's getting no help
it's he's it's falling on deaf ears one
of the last times he went to DC one of
his fundraisers got arrested he had to
turn around and come back again
everybody was looking this was very
suspect was this the Biden
Administration a little critical of of
our mayor because he was critical of Joe
Biden MH Jessica why won't Joe Biden do
a deal with Republicans on immigration I
think he's going to you do yeah I do I
I'm not sure if it'll be exactly the
text that we are seeing right now in our
lifetime yeah well listen tying it to
two Aid packages that are deeply
important to him and important to the
American people the Israel package more
so than the Ukraine package but you know
I think that he's done a pretty good job
of all also connecting the dots on that
but yes I think he's going to and I was
revisiting today um
Obama's immigration policies and he was
known as the deporter in Chief he
deported three million people while he
was here he was the first president
since Reagan to leave office with the
same amount of undocumented people as
when he entered under George Bush for
instance who people I'm sure in their
heads would think was much harsher on
immigration cuz that's what you
typically associate with a republican
they're an extra 2 million people
who came in during that time and Obama
left office an icon had increased
Latino's support in the party it didn't
backfire on him at at all and I think
that there's a lot of playing this game
like oh I don't want to upset the
progressive base of all this and they're
very loud online right very powerful
social media accounts G give great
interviews Etc but that's not how people
vote right that's what we saw in 2020 no
one would have thought Joe Biden would
be the nominee right if you just went
off of what blue check marks were saying
um so I think he is going to do a deal
we just saw some pretty nasty video they
have these immigrants now and and I
don't even know what they're dressing
them in it just looks really sad well
that that train video is incredible and
for the last two weeks we've seen uh on
one day in Arizona 12,000 people came
through a checkpoint 12,000 people and
here's the kicker Bill maluan had this
amazing report about how he will
interview migrants as are coming across
sometimes he talks to one guy he's from
Africa he's like Why'd You Come well my
country's economic situation is terrible
I'm looking for a job and I want to go
to New York Bill gets his
number contacts him the guy has made it
to New York he had his Asylum hearing he
said that the government in his in his
country was trying to persecute him so
he was granted Asylum but we have him on
camera yeah saying that he came for an
economic reason if you say economic
reason you get deported immediately so
we have them on camera and it's just one
of those things where there's no system
where you could figure that out the
other thing that 43 told Obama initially
his advice on the way out was I know you
want to do Healthcare but I'm telling
you you can get immigration done and you
should do it first before you try to get
health healthare done and I think all of
us would have been much better off the
last thing I would say is we had a guy
on today he was a a reporter in Mexico
he said that a lot of these people as
soon as they get across the border they
take a selfie and they send it to their
family with no words
but that selfie is the code that I made
it you should come
to so the system is totally broken and
the Biden Administration you are at 33%
approval immigration is a top three
concern and why don't you just take the
win get the Ukraine and Israel money and
work with the Republicans except for at
this point I think Senate Republicans
will go for it but House Republicans may
not yeah he it in the 20s on approval on
immigration that is true Jesse uh but
this is the key to open borders the word
Asylum it's the essentially translated
into open sesame even if you built a
wall That's the permanent doorway in a
wall wouldn't stop it and you could you
have to be frank about this when you're
when you're looking at the people coming
across they aren't escaping political
persecution they're a lot of them
especially the men look healthy happy
and fit uh many with roller bags they
look like they're they're going on a
vacation uh they it's not the way you
looked at they give me you're hungry and
tired
and once again it Bears repeating the
obvious lie of the left if America in
Western Civilization is one that is
steeped in systemic race racism and
Relentless oppression why are millions
of black and brown people flocking into
this Bastion of hate what kind of good
squad member could invite such poor
souls into a living hell in which they
will only be persecuted in a life of
misery and speaking of the
squad take Elana Omar you know perfect
example of exploiting the values of a
great country in order to subvert those
values she came here to open arms and
paid us back by castigating and demonize
this country and if you doubt me just
ask her brother and or husband hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else